skandal auf der kunstausstellung
documenta sind weitere antisemitische
zeichnungen aufgetaucht wir erinnern uns
bundespräsident frank walter steinmeier
hatte die veranstaltung groß eröffnet
gemeinsam mit
kulturstaatsministerin claudia roth die
hatte vorher immer wieder gesagt es gibt
hier keinen antisemitismus zwei tage
später auf einem bild taucht ein schwein
mit davidstern auf am kopf steht die
aufschrift mossad ganz klar hier wird
die mittelalterliche tradition
fortgeführt juden als schweine
darzustellen und damit nicht genug in
der kritik steht auch ein projekt mit
dem namen gaza guernica eines
palästinensischen künstlers der setzt
berühmte gemälde mit bildern von
israelischen anti terror operation
zusammen so dass dabei auch ns
vergleiche mit den israelischen
streitkräften fallen ein thema über das
wir sprechen müssen bei uns im studio
jetzt bild meinungs- chef philippe
piatti hallo philipp
was vor dass du jetzt was muss passieren
nach diesen weiteren bildern die
aufgetaucht sind bei der documenta man
könnte eigentlich aus der dokumente
kunstschau direkt ein museum machen und
zwar ein museum für antisemitismus in
deutschland im jahr
ich glaube dass die kunstschau als
solche so dermaßen beschädigt ist dass
man sie eigentlich dicht machen müsste
denn die neue leitung der dokumente die
weigert sich weiterhin
irgendwas zu überprüfen denn das fordern
ja ganz viele experten und politiker
dass man sich einmal alle kunstwerke
zumindest mal systematisch an schaut und
sagt hoppala hier ist noch ein bisschen
was antisemitisches dabei allein das zu
fordern weil es weil es die
notwendigkeit dafür gibt es schon glaube
ich peinlich genug für deutschland und
da das einfach nicht getan wird ich
glaube ich müsste man das ding
einstellen ansonsten werden wir in den
kommenden tagen und wochen ja immer
wieder neue funde haben wo juden als
schweine als kindermörder als
vergewaltiger und massenmörder gezeigt
werden denn das haben uns die dokumente
die alte dokumente leitung und auch dass
claudia roth eingebrockt sie haben die
warnung vor antisemitismus vor der
dokumente immer wieder weggewischt und
ja das ist jetzt das resultat und dass
claudia roth gerade angesprochen sie
weigert sich weiterhin zurückzutreten
obwohl die jüdische allgemeine und auch
weitere stimmen dies bereits mehrfach
gefordert haben welche konsequenzen
müssen sie jetzt ziehen tja claudia roth
versucht ja von anfang an in die
offensive zu gehen und besonders laut
die dokumente zu kritisieren und die
schuld schön abzuladen bei der documenta
leitung aber sie ist natürlich mit
verantwortlich sie ist
kulturstaatsministerin ihr haus
finanziert die dokumente mit und auch
sie wurde ganz konkret vom zentralrat
der juden gewarnt vor der eröffnung der
dokumente sie wurde darauf angesprochen
dass es dort auf jeden fall
antisemitismus geben wird weil
beispielsweise jüdische künstler aus
israel einfach nicht eingeladen wurde
weil die kuratoren eine indonesische
gruppe auf der documenta wirklich eine
große nähe haben zur antisemitischen
boykottbewegung bdst hat das alles weg
gewischt wird weggeschaut solange es nur
ging hat erklärt sie sich freut dass die
dokumente für sie eine tolle geschichte
ist dass sie sich bloß nicht als kultur
polizei aufspielen will ja jetzt hat sie
ihren ersten skandal also schlechter
kann eine amtszeit für eine
kulturstaatsministerin nicht beginnen
und vielleicht wäre es das beste wenn
sie auch bald einfach aufhört wie
intensiv erlebst du dass antisemitismus
problem in deutschland
tja ich glaube dass das dokument der
documenta skandal wirft ein licht auf
wenn eine bestimmte szene in der
antisemitismus tatsächlich floriert das
ist eine art von antisemitismus die ich
zum beispiel jetzt nicht direkt er
lieber weil ich bin hier in der
redaktion und
aber dieser antisemitismus herrscht im
kultur und kunst betrieb und das ist
seit jahren bekannt und jetzt gipfelt
das eben auf der documenta dort nimmt
man also in diesem deutschen kunden
kunst und kulturbetrieb dort nimmt man
antisemitismus vor allem antisemitismus
wenn er sich an israel arbeitet einfach
nicht mehr ernst im gegenteil man
versucht seit jahren
antisemiten wirklich eine heimat zu
geben und das irgendwie umzudeuten zu
sagen naja diese menschen kommen aus dem
globalen süden und nur wenn die juden
doof hinten heißt das nicht dass
antisemitismus ist wir können die als
deutsche nicht belehren also man
versucht ja ganz krude theorien
aufzustellen und ich erlebe das glaube
ich wie jeder andere mensch einfach mit
mit fassungslosigkeit und
deswegen ist es wirklich fast sogar
sagen es ist gut dass es mal so
öffentlich passiert dass die
öffentlichkeit wirklich miterlebt was
diese szene hier angerichtet hat all das
was wir auf der documenta sehen worüber
wir uns empören können was sonst
wirklich so sehr ins auge fällt all das
ist das resultat
dessen was der deutschen kulturbetrieb
seit jahren treibt und vielleicht werden
ja konsequenzen gezogen bezüglich der
dokumente vielen dank philippi ad hoc
bild meinung chef
[Musik]